wir kennen sie als die sexy Ulknudel
Sonja Kraus sie tut ja ihren Dienst in
der Talkshow wieder Aufbereitungsanlage
Talk Talk wo sie sich über den einen
oder anderen Gast ein wenig lustig macht
sie selbst hat ein relativ hartes Leben
hinter sich und darüber hat sie ein Buch
geschrieben bzw eigentlich nicht über
ihr Leben sondern was man daraus machen
kann also quasi ein Ratgeber wie man
auch mit dem harten Leben super zurecht
kommt und sogar was besseres draus
machen kann der Titel ist wenn das Leben
dir eine Zitrone gibt gib frag nach Salz
und Tequila kann man sich ganz leicht
merken den Buchtitel warum der so lang
ist und wie man sich am besten merken
kann das wird sie bei uns erklären und
sie wird auf eure Fragen Antworten auf
die nutzerfragen hier noch mal der
Hinweis am besten nur eine Frage stellen
den Infotext lesen und kreativ sein dann
habt ihr riesen Chancen dass eure Frage
auch an Sonja Kraus dran kommt wir
drücken die Daumen also die Sonja und
ich